Let's look a bit more in depth at how this box in space actually gets
positioned and defined internally. First, we define our camera object as
looking down the world's negative z axis and oriented so that the top of the
camera is facing along the plus y axis. The camera starts at the origin, just
like other objects. The first step is to move the camera to where we want to
make an image from. We also tilt and orient the camera as desired. This is
similar to how we have been orienting objects all along. We define some sort of
rotation in translation to get your camera into place. We ignore scale, we're
just trying to set up the camera in space. Giving the camera a position is
simple enough. To compute the rotation needed to orient our camera, we use
what's called a look at system. This is pretty much what it sounds like. You
define a target location for what direction you want the camera to look. This
defines the negative z axis for the camera's frame of reference. In other
words, how it's pointing in the world. So here I have a real live camera, it
even works. And with my z axis here, that tells me which way it's pointing, but
unfortunately it doesn't tell me which way is up. It still has this one degree
of freedom. So what we do, is we also define an up-vector of some sort. This
vector gives us some guidance as to which way to orient the top of the camera.
Typically in 3JS, we'll pass an up-vector such as zero, one, zero, the plus y
axis as the up-vector. Given our view vector and this up-vector, we'd like to
form a matrix that defines a whole frame of reference for our camera. We know
where we want this z axis to look along. But we want to know where the camera's
y and x axis end up. By specifying a general up direction, we do this. For
example, say we have a camera pointing in some direction. Looking along its
negative z axis. If we give an up direction, we can find the direction pointing
to the right of the camera. Which is the x axis. By taking the cross product of
this z axis and our up vector. Now we have two axis locked down. Camera z and
camera x. We can find the true up direction, the camera's y axis, by then
taking the cross product of the x and z axis. Remember that the cross product
of two vectors will give us the vector that's perpendicular to both of them.
This may all sound a bit odd and like a lot of work but is extremely common.
It's probably the place where I use the cross product the most. The whole point
here is that given a view direction and an up vector as a hint, we can get a
frame of reference for the camera. We'll often use the worlds plus y axis as
our up vector hint, but it all depends. Say we're a hawk soaring over some
terrain. We're looking straight down, which would be looking down the y axis of
our world. If we use the world's y axis as our hint, it doesn't make much
sense. We define the negative z axis the camera's looking along, and the y axis
for the camera's up direction. As vectors in exactly opposite directions. This
is not very useful. In this case our up vector is more like the direction
pointing out of the top of our hawk's head, the direction it's flying. Now that
the up vector is not parallel to the look at direction, we can form a good
frame of reference for the hawk.